protests gathered at the Texas state
capital following newly revealed video
showing the controversial traffic stop
of Sandra bland the 39 second cellphone
fit footage recorded by bland shows the
moments before her arrest in 2015 she
was found dead three days later hanging
in her jail cell
her family is calling for a new
investigation Matea viene al is in
Dallas Madea good morning well good
morning Sandra Bland's family says until
recently they had never seen this cell
phone video now her arrest actually
added fuel to an already heated
conversation about how minorities are
treated by police right now you're gonna
get a first-hand look of how this arrest
went down from Sandra Bland's eyes well
you can step on out now as Texas trooper
brian encinia demanded Sandra bland step
out of her car she grabbed her cellphone
and began recording to drag me out of my
own car get out of the car the arrest
was captured on dashcam video but this
cell phone video has not been publicly
seen until now
encinia pulled over bland in 2015 for a
failure to signal a lane change the
encounter quickly escalated the 28 year
old was arrested and booked in the
Waller County Jail three days later she
was found dead in her cell her death was
ruled a suicide the video was obtained
by the nonprofit news organization the
investigative network lands family says
it's proof she should have never been
detained in Sydney up said he feared for
his life this video clearly shows from
Sandy's vantage point that she was doing
nothing more than asking questions canon
lambert is the family's attorney and
helped them settle with Waller County
and the state for nearly two million
dollars he says prosecutors never gave
him the video if they had it and they
walked away from prosecuting it is very
difficult to understand encinia was
fired after he was indicted for lying
about the traffic stop but the perjury
charge was later dropped when he agreed
to never work in law enforcement again
Jim Lewis represented him the
tragedy that was this young lady's death
should have never happened it was not
trooper instantaneous fault and it
happened the Texas Department of Public
Safety says this video is not new and
they did not conceal it also right now a
Democratic presidential hopeful bet TOA
Roark who is from Texas as well as other
state legislators are asking that
Bland's arrest and the case be reopened
right now Nora
Lorie Maria thank you